Major breaking news as all indications
point to Mississippi burning is coming
to the state of Virginia as Army Dylan,
the head of the Second Amendment group
at the Department of Justice and the
head of the Civil Rights Division, has
just flagged for America the fact that
Virginia has gone fully insane when it
comes to violating the right to keep and
bear arms. Let's break down what all
this means when we come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
fourbox of Dina, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Bar
and I'm proud to say the top voice of
the second amendment in America. Thank
you. 2025 and 2026 Gundy's awards. All
right, folks. This is a big deal. Harmy
Dylan, the confirmed attorney who is in
charge of the United States Department
of Justice's Office of Civil Rights,
who's already sued various jurisdictions
for violating the Second Amendment over
their abusive licensing practices, who's
already argued in front of the United
States Court of Appeals for the Seventh
Circuit out of Chicago in the Barnett
case that magazine and AR-15 bans
violate the Second Amendment, who's
already filed a brief in the Cheeseman
case and the association New Jersey
rifle and pistol association's case in
the third circuit out of Delaware,
Pennsylvania and New Jersey. That's the
same Harmy Dylan. That's right. She is
just essentially flagged on X
basically a post by an important
Virginia operative Shane uh Snavely who
is a businessman there, former veteran
of the US Army among other things and a
Republican there in Virginia. uh he has
flagged the nine gun control laws, the
nine gun control bills that have passed
the House and the Senate there in
Virginia that are now awaiting signature
uh in the middle of April or not. We'll
talk about that in a moment by the
governor Abigail Spanberger.
Now, Harmony Dylan using her official
account at the Department of Justice has
noted
with a quizzical look a post by Mr. navy
pointing out indeed that Virginia's gone
hog wild in violating the Second
Amendment and that they've enacted all
these laws that are targeted towards
simply ordinary ordinary American gun
owners while at the same time Virginia
specifically passed no laws dealing with
actual criminal behavior by actual
criminals that engage in, for example,
violence with firearms or otherwise.
Needless to say, we know that modern day
gun control has nothing to do with
public safety. Modern day gun control
law is all about making America into not
America. That we will be America in name
only. that are private gun ownership
focused, self-defense focused right to
keep and bear arms that makes the United
States special with independent
self-reliant
self-reliant Americans will go by the
waysides. They want this country
neutered so that the only people that
have guns is our government. Remember,
these anti-gunners do not want you and
they do not want me and the rest of us
peeons in their eyes to possess
firearms. They're perfectly content to
have the government with guns because
remember the government will use guns to
protect themselves and the government
will use guns to enforce the anti-gun
laws. So these anti-gunners are not
really anti-gunners. They're just anti
you and me having guns. Well, Har Dylan,
who's been a strong supporter of the
Second Amendment at the Department of
Justice, including filing several legal
cases in support of the Second Amendment
and several legal briefs, has just
flagged the following post by Mr.
Snavely over there in Virginia. So,
let's start with the post and then we'll
go to Harmy Dylan and we'll talk about
what this means for gun owners in
Virginia. Let's start with the post. Mr.
Shane Snavely posts the following.
Virginia just passed nine gun bills in
one session. Assault weapons ban, ghost
gun felony, carry reciprocity gutted,
mandatory home storage. same session
they killed mandatory minimums on
violent criminals who actually use guns.
The nine bills include SB749 which is
assault weapons ban, SB27, a gun
industry liability expansion, SB38
prohibited person transfers, HB40
uh ghost gun ban for felony making it a
felony. HB19 which is the dating
violence prohibition. HB 110 which is
the visible handgun in a car for $500
fine law 8 SB that's SB115
carry reciprocity is being gutted and
HB229 which is a mental health facility
ban i.e a form of census of place law
and then there's HB871
which deals with mandatory home storage
and then Mr. Snavely goes on to say that
all nine of these have been enrolled and
the governor deadline to sign or choose
not to sign is April 13th. And he also
wanted to note that SB79, which was
mandatory minimums for repeat violent
gun criminals, apparently did not pass.
It was killed in the same session, same
committee, same chair. Nine bills for
illegal gun owners, zero bills for
actual criminals. That's not safety
according to Mr. Snavely. That's an
agenda. So that was the post that Mr.
Snavely put on X. But then Harmy Dylan
comes off and flags this exact post.
Check it out.
I think it's quite significant that
Harmony Dylan, who is the head of the
Second Rights uh second amendment rights
unit at the Donald Trump Pam Bonnie
Department of Justice, has flagged this
because it is clear that her team over
there at DOJ is tracking this. And what
does that mean? I think it's good news
for us. As you know, it is clear to me
that the Department of Justice under
Trump and Bondi are waiting for the
Seventh Circuit Court of Appeals in the
Barnett case. Those various cases
decided originally in favor of the
Second Amendment by District Court Judge
Steven McGlin and that excellent,
excellent opinion over 100 pages long as
I recall. Now, we're waiting for the
three judge panel of the Seventh Circuit
to make a decision on Judge McGllin's
excellent ruling. You may recall Judge
McGlin uh there in the Southern District
of Illinois found that all these various
Illinois gun bans were unconstitutional
as they clearly are under Heler. And of
course the seventh circuit court of
appeals stayed the effect of that order
and then heard oral argument. But Har
Dylan on behalf of the Trump
administration literally went in front
of the seventh circuit and pointed out
that their beas decision uh which
violates the Heler rule. doesn't follow
the proper protocols and methodology for
deciding an arisban case. She literally
looked the three judge panel in the face
and said, including Judge Frank
Easterber, that you guys are totally
wrong on your law. You got to get it
right or we're going to the Supreme
Court. That is essentially also what she
said. Although she did not attack the
third circuit, she did put in a brief on
behalf of the Department of Justice in
the US Court of Appeals for the Third
Circuit out of Pennsylvania, Delaware,
and New Jersey arguing that in the
Cheeseman and the Association of New
Jersey Rifle and Pistol Association or
pistol clubs uh brief uh that indeed
also the New Jersey ban on magazines and
AR-15 semi-automatic rifles violates the
law. So Harmy Dylan flagging the fact
that she's tracking in a public way
what's going on in Virginia, I think
will tell us that as soon as these laws
go into effect, they are going to get
sued by the Trump body, Department of
Justice. Now, as a word of the wise, the
state of Virginia falls inside the
jurisdiction of the United States Court
of Appeals for the Fourth Circuit, which
is an absolutely terrible court when it
comes to the Second Amendment rights.
It's run by uh essentially Harvey
Wilkinson who's like 99 years old and
thinks that you can use a machine gun to
cut bodies in half according to his
supposed uh experience in the National
Guard. At least that's what he indicated
at an oral argument a while back. Uh
it's a terrible court, terrible
precedent and we will get no relief
there in the fourth circuit. But there's
no doubt in my view that the US Court of
the US Supreme Court is also watching
this because not only is the Department
of Justice tracking these sorts of cases
as indicated by or is reflected by Harmy
Dylan's uh note to the Shane Snavely
Post. It's also clear they're filing
briefs in those cases of Barnett and
Cheeseman. And I suspect that when those
decisions come out in the seventh
circuit and or the third circuit, those
will likely be the vehicle in my view
that will ultimately go to the US
Supreme Court and be one of those AR-15
semi-automatic rifle ban cases that
Justice Brett Kavanaaugh indicated the
court needs to hear in the next term or
two. And that term or two includes the
current term, which expires in June of
2026. And the next term would be the one
that starts in October 2026. And I think
there's a very good chance we're going
to see an AR-15 ban case, maybe even a
magazine case, uh, you know, pop up
there this fall, which would be huge
because, as I point out before, uh, if
the Supreme Court takes those cases, I
see a almost 0% chance that we lose
those. Obviously, anything's possible,
but I think we will have a very good
chance of winning those cases. And the
Trump Bondi Harmy Dylan Department of
Justice will 100% be fighting for our
rights in both the semi-automatic ban
case and the air and the AR-15 ban case
and of course the magazine ban case if
those are granted by the Supreme Court.
And I think there's a good chance of
that happening. Now, at the start of
this video, I made a reference to
Mississippi Burning, which of course,
Mississippi Burning is the very famous
movie that starred Jean Hackman talking
about uh the Department of Justice going
down to Mississippi to u just get rid of
segregation, to stop the oppression, to
stop the tyranny uh and the rights
violation of the African-Americans in
the state of Mississippi uh back in the
50s and early 60s, as I recall. And I
the reason why I use that as a metaphor
here is because what's going on with the
second amendment in the state of
Virginia is they are trying to get the
second amendment. These bills that Judge
Judge Governor Spanberger is either not
going to sign and then allow it to go
into effect or will sign and allow to go
into effect. Either way, remember under
Virginia law, if these laws are are
passed by the Senate and the House and
they go to the governor, the government
can sign them in the law or the
government can simply do nothing. And if
the governor does nothing under Virginia
law, they become the law of the state,
in this case, the Commonwealth of
Virginia. So, I'm sure these laws will
all become the laws. Um, I don't see a
scenario where she vetos these laws. Uh,
because obviously the former CIA agent,
uh, Abigail Spamberger knows that her
mission along with her Bangladeshi born,
uh, state senator there, it's all
designed to take away guns from those
people that can resist the tyranny that
the anti-Americans have planned for us.
Because there's no reason why you want
to take away guns from the people that
are most law-abiding in America unless
you have very big plans for them and you
fear that an armed population is going
to get in the way. Which is why in
Europe and in all these other parts all
these gun rights have been eviscerated.
And as a consequence now, for example,
in the United Kingdom, you get to go to
prison if you put something on social
media that uh is hate speech as they
define it, which in America would be
viewed as just exercising your right to
express your opinion on public policy
matters. But in parts of Europe, that is
a no. And that is why, you know,
political parties get banned in places
like Germany and, you know, leaders of
political party in places like France
get kicked out and cannot run for office
again. All of which they would do to
MAGA. All of which they would do to
Donald Trump, all of which they would do
to Republicans if they had the
opportunity to do so. And they know that
they cannot create the quote unquote
utopia that they want to create if
Americans are armed, independent, and
self-reliant. And that is why they have
to get the guns. They have to get the
guns because you cannot go full
totalitarian on an armed population.
It's just not possible for obvious
reasons, which is exactly what our
founding fathers understood that if you
want to thwart domestic tyranny by the
government, you have to make sure that
your citizens are armed. And that's why
all of these things that target nothing
more than the lawful use of firearms is
all designed to destroy American gun
culture, which is a unique form of gun
culture. Because like unlike other types
of potential gun cultures to the extent
other countries have them, we are unique
because our gun culture it focuses on
private gun ownership on the one hand
and it focuses on self-defense. We're
not just about shooting sporting clays
or you know clay pigeons. No, we are
about using firearms for self-defense
against all forms of tyranny. And that
can run everywhere from uh uh stopping
terrorism, stopping domestic
insurrections, stopping you know
government tyranny, stopping foreign
invaders, stopping street criminals,
stopping cartel members, and even going
after and stopping animal attacks. All
this was understood to be a form of
tyranny that threatens your life, the
life of your loved ones, the life of
your community, and so on. And the
founding fathers thought this was such
an important thing that they literally
wrote it in to the original bill of
rights in 1791. And just as a reminder
in light of all this, the Department of
Justice under Pam Bonnie, Donald Trump,
and Harmy Dylan 100% have the legal
authority to bring lawsuits and to take
steps on behalf of the Department of
Justice to make sure that fundamental
individual rights are vindicated. Again,
my reference to the movie Mississippi
Burning is exactly that, where the power
of the federal government was able to go
down to Mississippi during the so-called
civil rights movement and basically
vindicate the fundamental rights of the
African-Americans that were being, you
know, uh, victimized uh, and uh,
deprived of their rights uh, during the
civil rights era. And there all those
laws, all those statutes, all that legal
authority still exists for DOJ to go in
these various jurisdictions which
they've already done in like I believe
the Virgin Islands or Guam. Um I think
they've done it in Los Angeles County
when it comes to licensing uh into
Chicago into New Jersey into DC. All
these sorts of things they've been
doing, using the power of the federal
government to come forth on behalf of
the DOJ, on behalf of this
administration to vindicate the
fundamental rights of individual
Americans when they are oppressed or
infringed upon by rogue state and local
government officials, which obviously is
about ready to start happening in
earnest there in the Commonwealth of
Virginia. All right, folks. There you
have it. I think it is bad news what's
going on in Virginia, but I think it's
good news that Harmy Dylan and the DOJ
officials are paying attention to
Virginia. So, it's bad news on the one
hand, good news on the other hand that
the cavalry may be riding to the rescue.
But again, we all understand that the
history of the future is yet to be
written. So, there you have it. Make
sure you follow me over there on X4box
and Diner. Don't forget to subscribe
both the uh YouTube and the Rumble and I
look forward to talking to all of you
real soon here at the Var Boxes Diner.
Orders up. Table 2. A